marché au cadran totalement vide cela
n'était pas arrivé depuis 2007 lors de
la dernière épidémie de fièvre
catarrhale d'ordinaire près de sept
cents bovins transitent ici avant la
vente du lundi matin une perte sèche
pour les éleveurs il ya des éleveurs qui
sont dans le désarroi
ce matin qu'ils ont d'être est à honorer
et qui n'ont pas fait leur barre toi
hier tout en en parlant j'en ai la chair
de poule
parce qu'en plus on doit nourrir nos
animaux parce qu'on est face c'est pas
parce que il pleut il pleut depuis
avant-hier on est face à une sécheresse
et où il ya plus de stocks ou l'aliment
est très cher et les éleveurs demain ne
feront pas face
quinze mille euros de manque à gagner
pour ce marché des exportations
momentanément interrompue dans un rayon
de 150 km autour du foyer infectieux la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
pour les éleveurs il avait trouvé de
nouveaux débouchés
depuis un an la france était même
considéré comme indemne de cas de fièvre
catarrhale une embellie de courte durée
au niveau des bovins c'est la perte
d'activité la plus importante et pour
les ovins on a beaucoup d'agneau qui
sortent aussi nous approchions de la
fête de l'aïd el kébir et beaucoup de
producteurs préparent des agneaux pour
cette fête qui est importante en france
et fait annuler a en fait que sont les
commerces y arrive pas dans les 10 jours
qui viennent et au niveau valorisation
ils feront ils seront pénalisés des
contrôles vétérinaires et de vaccination
vont être mises en place pour contenir
cette maladie chez les bovins les ovins
les caprins principaux symptômes la
fièvre n'est pas seulement il peut y
avoir également des conséquences sur
l'aspect de fertilité de reproduction au
sein des cheptels
en aucun cas ses conséquences et ses
éléments ne sont transmissibles à
l'homme le marché au cadran va rouvrir
ses portes pour les auvents seuls les
éleveurs situe à proximité du marché
pourront vendre leurs animaux destinés à
l'abattoir